The massive migration of wildebeests
across the Serengeti
has a huge impact on the ecosystem.
One overlooked aspect
has been what happens
when the wildebeests drown
during river crossings
Every year, 1.2 million wildebeests
move across the savannah,
consuming more than 4,500 tons
of grass every day
in an 1800-kilometer circuit
between Kenya and Tanzania
as they follow the rains.
Their herding instinct is strong because
even though being in a crowd
leads to stiff competition for food,
this part of Africa has so many lions
& other predators that strength in numbers wins out—
even if it means sometimes
blindly swimming toward death.
Almost annually, thousands drown in river crossings,
often because the opposite banks are too steep or
too many are trying to cross at one time.
For the past six years,
researchers have taken stock
of the pileup of carcasses,
surveyed the parade of scavengers
assisting in their decomposition,
and used modeling and chemical analyses
to track where nutrients provided by
these dead animals wind up in the food chain.
About 6500 animals drown each year,
dumping the equivalent of 10 blue whale carcasses
into the river.
Half of that biomass is bones,
which take 7 years to decay
Carcasses accumulate at
bends in the river and outcroppings
Annually they add about 13 tons of phosphorous,
25 tons of nitrogen
and 107 tons of carbon to the ecosystem
The nutrients come in pulses
that last about a month each
and can temporarily double,
or even quadruple some nutrient levels.
Vultures and storks flock to the site for the feast,
and likely move wildebeest derived nutrients
inland after they fly away
Crocodiles, too, are known to congregate.
Chemical analyses showed
that up to 50% of the diet of local fish
comes from the carcasses when they're present.
After the meat disappears,
the remaining bones begin to support
a film of microbes
that in turn become food for fish
and other river-dwellers.
On the positive side,
the wildebeest drownings
only involve about about 0.7% of the total herd
Illegal harvesting, starvation and predation
take many more.